schneiden sie sich besser an denn es
erwarten sie haar sträubende aufnahmen
ob reingefahren oder platt gemacht
haarscharf vorbei oder mittenrein
kleine kameras auf dem armaturenbrett
sogenannte des camps zeichnen gnadenlos
alles auf
in vielen ländern boomt der markt für
des camps die aufnahmen sollen bei
unfällen als beweismittel dienen und vor
betrug schützen die abkassieren wollen
kein wunder also dass immer mehr
verblüffende videoclips im umlauf sind
halten sie sich gut fest wir starten
unsere reise um die welt mit bildern die
ihnen garantiert den atem rauben werden
los geht's das sind die spektakulärsten
des camps und keine sorge
niemand wird hier ernsthaft verletzt
auch wenn es manchmal knapp wird
richtig knapp
dieses mal anmutiges auto ballett auf
spiegelglatter straße ein park versuche
die furchtbar in die hose gehen
streithähne in der rush hour
und waghalsige stunts die man besser
nicht nach machen sollte
[Musik]
das hat bestimmt weh getan
achtung gefahrenzone
im straßenverkehr mischt mutter natur
oft gehörig mit ganz so als wolle sie
daran erinnern wer hier eigentlich der
stärkere ist ob erdrutsch oder
einbrechende straßen sie schlägt meist
ohne vorwarnung zu
lawinen gibt es nur in den bergen falsch
er schaufelt ein vorbeifahrender zug den
schnee auf die daneben liegende straße
und bringt so den verkehr zum stillstand
so mancher autofahrer wird sich jetzt
wünschen er hätte den zug genommen von
extremer kälte zu feuersbrünsten
dieser fahrer steuert mitten durch einen
wald brachte eine szene wie aus einem
katastrophenfilm die hitze und der rauch
sind lebensgefährlich die bewohner der
kanadischen gemeinde fort mcmurray
riskieren alles um den wütenden flammen
zu entkommen
[Musik]
ein betonmischer fahrzeug und ein pkw
der im dicht an den fersen hängt ob der
wagen gleich eine beton dusche kriegt
nein in diesem fall erwischt es den lkw
wie einen elefanten der über dünnes eis
stampft
wasser hat das lösliche gestein unter
der fahrbahn ausgewaschen da war der
betonmischer einfach zu schwer
vielleicht kann er das loch ja direkt
wieder auffüllen
früher gab es noch solide
handwerksarbeit was wohl die alten römer
zu dieser straße sagen würden die wie
eine missratene carrerabahn aufbricht
dieses taxi gibt ihr den rest das
ergebnis ein klaffendes loch zum glück
kommt es nicht zu einem ernsten unfall
[Musik]
zähfließender verkehr kann nervtötend
sein doch hier in sibirien haben die
autofahrer den richtigen riecher als sie
diese verdächtig aussehende stelle
langsam umfahren im gegensatz zur
fahrbahn sind ihre befürchtungen wohl
begründet
[Musik]
das war knapp
china dieser fahrer schlängelt sich auf
serpentinen durch die berge als er
allerdings geröll auf der straße bemerkt
meldet sich sein siebter sinn er setzt
zurück eine kluge entscheidung da der
abhang zu rutschen beginnt plötzlich
zieht ein anderer fahrer vorbei
zum glück kann auch er rechtzeitig
stoppen bevor das dicke ende kommt
der nächste autofahrer hat glück im
unglück
er wird mit voller wucht von einer
schlammlawine überrollt
wie durch ein wunder steigt er völlig
unverletzt aus sein auto muss jetzt aber
dringend in die waschanlage
[Musik]
straßen krieg
so ziemlich jeder autofahrer wird
irgendwann zeuge von gewalt im
straßenverkehr von beleidigungen und
leichten handgreiflichkeiten bis hin zu
brutalen körperlichen attacken meist
bleibt einer dabei auf der strecke
in russland werden die dinge schon mal
hemdsärmelig geregelt auch
streitigkeiten auf der straße zwei
männer steigen aus ihrem wagen um fahrer
und beifahrer im auto hinter sich zu
attackieren
anfangs lassen sich die anderen nicht
provozieren
doch die angreifer lassen nicht locker
bis die attackierten den spieß umdrehen
und ihnen eine ordentliche schlägerei
liefern
nur der typ auf dem rücksitz hält sich
vornehm zurück
hoffentlich ruft er gerade die polizei
[Musik]
paris die stadt der liebe aber wenn es
um parkplätze geht hört mit der liebe
auf die junge frau und ihr begleiter
behaupten den parkplatz zuerst gesehen
zu haben den sich das ältere ehepaar
geschnappt hat
ihr protest stößt auf taube ohren und
der streit scheint beigelegt doch rache
serviert man am besten kalt die junge
frau kommt zurück und zerkratzt mit
ihrem schlüssel den autolack
[Musik]
ein aufmerksamer anwohner filmt die
retourkutsche
[Musik]
rücksichtsloses verhalten im
straßenverkehr ist gefährlich noch
gefährlicher wird es wenn die person am
steuer eine waffe zieht nicht genug dass
der fahrer beinahe einen unfall
verursacht hätte er droht den anderen
verkehrsteilnehmern auch noch offenbar
mit einer schusswaffe
dank der aufnahme kann der mann später
festgenommen werden tatsächlich handelte
es sich nur um eine leuchtpistole wie
man sie zum beispiel auf boten im
notfall einsetzt
niemand mag leute die sich vordringen
aber wer wird denn deswegen gleich
überreagieren
das nennt man wohl sich vor wut ins
eigene fleisch schneiden manchmal ist es
besser tief durchzuatmen und bis zehn zu
zählen
[Musik]
betrunkene kerle die sich barfuß prügeln
mitten auf der autobahn
wo könnte das ein richtig in russland
darauf einen wodka diese stockbesoffen
kampfhähne liefern sich einen
abenteuerlichen schaukampf bis der eine
den anderen über die beton absperrung
wird
doch der ist im nu zurück und die
rauferei geht in die nächste runde bis
irgendwann der kater einsetzt
[Musik]
vorsicht glatteis
manche freuen sich über spiegelglatte
straßen
doch im straßenverkehr ist kein platz
für unfug schnee und eis können auf der
fahrbahn im handumdrehen eine
rutschfeste ins verderben machen
da hilft nur eins vorsichtig fahren
vierradantrieb hin oder her auf
eisglatter straße sollte man nie voll in
die eisen gehen dieser suv kommt auf dem
highway schwer ins schleudern er dreht
sich um 180 grad und prallte um ein haar
frontal mit einem lkw zusammen
wenn väterchen frost in ein parkservice
übernimmt flutschen die autos wie von
selbst trotz vollem körpereinsatz können
die zuschauer die katastrophe nicht
verhindern eine massenkarambolage mit
neuen autos
bei winterwetter fährt man mit ruhe und
gelassenheit am besten
wer es eilig hat und waghalsig überholt
passiert einen tritt in den hintern
chicago in den usa als diese autos hier
abgestellt wurden war der sie wohl noch
zugefroren für manche offenbar eine
willkommene gelegenheit die parkgebühr
zu sparen den innenraum wieder
trockenzulegen dürfte weitaus teurer
werden
gibt es etwas an mutigeres als das
eisballett eines autos mit heckantrieb
bei der haltungsnote gibt es die volle
punktzahl
vorbildlich auf der straße gehalten
[Musik]
was tut man wenn man eine eisglatte
kurve bemerkt streuen oder eine kamera
aufstellen um das chaos zu filmen
da kommt endlich das streufahrzeug doch
für einige ist der tag bereits gelaufen
wer auf einer verschneiten fahrbahn die
spur wechselt sollte nicht ruckartig
lenken sonst wird schwierig die kuh vom
eis zu holen
dieser kanadier verliert für einen
moment die kontrolle über seinen truck
zum glück kommt er am ende mit einem
blechschaden davon
[Musik]
langsam fahren und frühzeitig bremsen
sind im winter oberstes gebot
[Musik]
auf spiegelglatten autobahnen kommt es
häufig zu unfällen je mehr autos
unterwegs sind
desto eher kraft ist hier hat es über
nacht geschneit am morgen sind zwei
fahrzeuge aufeinander geprallt und es
kamen noch 59 hinzu
an dieser kreuzung baumeln lose
drahtseile auf der straße
[Musik]
ein haarsträubender überschlag zum glück
hat der fahrer nur ein paar blaue
flecken davon getragen und ein
jobangebot als stuntman
immer ärger mit der polizei
[Applaus]
zusammenstöße mit der polizei gehen
selten gut aus vor allem für diejenigen
die sich mit dem gesetz anlegen am ende
sitzen die beamten meist am längeren
hebel
wenn man von einem polizisten
rausgewunken wird ist es nicht ratsam
hin zu ignorieren
dieses fluchtauto ist eine alte karre
und der flüchtige ein betrunkener ohne
führerschein anscheinend hatte auch die
hände nicht am lenkrad denn schon in der
nächsten kurve landet er in der
absperrung
der polizist fackelt nicht lange und
nimmt ihn fest
[Musik]
noch ein missglückter fluchtversuch
dieses mal ist es ein drogenabhängiger
der bei seiner verhaftung kaum
widerstand leistet
bei der durchsuchung des wagens
offenbart sich das ausmaß seiner sucht
unter drogeneinfluss auto zu fahren ist
ein schweres vergehen
[Musik]
diese schweren jungs sind mit einem
gestohlenen fahrzeug unterwegs
sie werden von einer zivilstreife
verfolgt und hinterlassen eine spur der
verwüstung
schließlich feiert ein beamter einen
warnschuss ab das spiel ist aus bei der
festnahme gehen die polizisten nicht
gerade zimperlich mit den männern um
verbrechen lohnt sich eben nicht
bürger die das gesetz kennen und
respektieren sind der traum jedes
polizisten bis sie ihr wissen gegen ihn
verwenden hier legt sich ein junger
naseweis mit einem bewaffneten beamten
an
das ist eine zivile verkehrskontrolle in
der scheinbar fast kaputt was weiß ich
dieses fahrzeug gehört der stadt das
verstößt gegen die
sicherheitsvorschriften
genau dafür habe ich neulich einen
strafzettel bekommt sein einwand ist
absolut nachvollziehbar der polizist
wird trotzdem unbeeindruckt
wir haben das recht unsere beamten zur
verantwortung zu ziehen insbesondere
wenn sie uns vor genau so was raus
schließlich reicht es den polizisten wir
heissen sie als polizist sind sie
verpflichtet sich
der polizist verrät ihm seinen namen
nicht aber bestimmt hat er sich das
nummernschild des besorgten bürgers
gemerkt
970 immer zweimal
high noon auf einer kreuzung in china
dieser halbnackte bruce lee fuchtelt mit
zwei hacke ballen rum und provoziert
eine ganze polizisten dann dreht er sich
um und ergreift die flucht der start
einer filmreifen verfolgungsjagd durch
die straßen
am ende nehmen die polizisten ihm die
klingen ab und ihn fest
jetzt wird eingepackt
und rein in die lücke aber jetzt da
neben nicht
zugegeben bei einer engen parklücke
hatte wohl jeder schon mal
schwierigkeiten doch bei manchen leuten
scheint das problem woanders zu liegen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wenn es beim ersten mal nicht klappt
versucht man es einfach noch mal wieder
nicht okay nächster versuch wenn es dann
immer noch nicht klappt
ab nach hause
[Musik]
man würde meinen dass mercedes fahrer
pfleglich mit ihrem wagen umgehen oder
auch nicht und da man sich gute manieren
nicht kaufen kann macht sich der rebell
aus dem staub als wäre nichts gewesen
sich beim einparken verschätzen und die
wand berühren das kann leicht passieren
aber es braucht schon einiges um durch
eine wand hindurch zu brechen
eine sekunde später und der wagen hätte
den mann erwischt knappe kiste
der halter dieses wagens denkt bestimmt
er hätte seinen wagen auf einem sicheren
parkplatz abgestellt
falsch gedacht dieses auto wird
nirgendwo mehr hin fach der wasser sturz
ist die folge eines geplatzten rohr es
auf dem dach
[Musik]
diese dame führt uns vor wie man mit
entschlossenheit und beharrlichkeit
selbst in die engste partner bekommt
hier und da ein kleiner schubs ein paar
beulen bemerkt doch eh keiner
und schon ist frau drin beim ausparken
klappt's etwas besser doch sie hat ihre
spuren hinterlassen
[Musik]
rückwärts einparken am straßenrand ist
die königsdisziplin
hier müssen alle geduldig abwarten bis
dieser fahrer es im schneckentempo in
die partner geschafft
als es langsam dunkel wird beschließt
seine frau die sache zu erledigen
[Musik]
so macht man das
nächstes mal fährt sie
[Musik]
ihr scheint jemand die kunst des
einparken zu beherrschen naja fast er
steht zwar einigermaßen nahe am
bordstein hat aber leider vergessen die
handbremse anzuziehen
kaum ist er weg macht sich das auto
selbstständig zuerst rammt es den
vorderwagen dann rollt es zielstrebig
auf zwei passanten zu die sich ihm mutig
entgegen stemmen
straßen stunts
manch einer hält sich für einen
angehenden stuntman vor allem wenn er
auf zwei rädern unterwegs ist dieser
tollkühne teufelskerl überschlägt sich
mehrfach
naja aller anfang ist schwer
viele landen auf den boden der tatsachen
und das kann ganz schön wehtun
dieser hans dampf in allen gassen will
der welt zeigen was er kann er führt
seine fahrkünste auf einer dreispurigen
schnellstraße vor das ist nicht nur
extrem gefährlich es kriegt auch noch
jeder mit wenn man so richtig vermasselt
der pizzafahrer ist offensichtlich
unterfordert und versucht sich nebenbei
als landpfarrer
hollywood muss wohl noch etwas warten
genau wie seine hungrigen kunden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
noch ein teufelskerl der die ganz große
nummer plant wird er über riesige
hindernisse springen
nein nur über zwei ziegelsteine und das
geht gründlich in die hose da tut der
staat schon beim zuschauen will
mit einer helmkamera können motorrad
asse ihre besten tricks aufnehmen und
ihre schlimmsten reinfällen einer camera
and geht eben nichts
zum glück ist es nur ein kleiner
blechschaden
[Musik]
noch ein möchtegern stuntman der einen
juli auf der autobahn vollführt
anfangs macht er sich gut bis er für die
kamera noch eins drauf legte
ups und die ganze gernhardts gesehen
nichts passiert seine kumpels bringen
ihn nach hause
dieser junge biker hat vor kurzem den
führerschein gemacht und sich seine
erste maschine zugelegt
während er geduldig darauf wartet dass
die ampel grün wird kommt ihm eine
ebenso waghalsige wie hirnverbrannte
idee
[Musik]
sechs autos und sein motorrad sind
hinüber er ist wie durch ein wunder nur
leicht verletzt
wenn man im straßenverkehr zur falschen
zeit am falschen ort ist kann es gehörig
eng werden
[Musik]
also fahren sie bitte immer vorsichtig
ob mit oder ohne das camp
[Musik]